من الرياض صباح الخير عبد الرحمن معنا
صباح الخير عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن تمام
عبد الرحمن بدنا نقول لك يا اهلا وسهلا
فيكم
ماذا عن تحري الهلايه عبد الرحمن بين
معانا شي ولا بعد اليوم
فعلا سمر يعني هناك جهود كبيره تبذلها
سلطات السعوديه كل عام لادخال التقنيه
الجديده تم اطلاق نظام الكتروني جديد في
السعوديه لاجراءات اثبات رؤيه الهلال
بدايه تطبيق هذا النظام ستكون مع اعترائه
هلال شهر رمضان هذا العام خلال يومين
المقبلين وزاره العدل قالت ان هذا النظام
سيوفر خاصيه التواصل المباشر بين المحاكم
والمراصد الفلكيه عبر البث المرئي الامر
الذي سينعكس على سرعه اصدار قرار المحكمه
العليا بشان دخول الاشهر القمريه خصوصا
اهله شهر رمضان المبارك وشوال وذي الحجه
كما يهدف النظام لحوكمه عمليات التراعي
اليه عبد الرحمن طبعا شهر رمضان مهم جدا
بالنسبه للاراضي المقدسه في مكه المكرمه
والمدينه المنوره احكي لنا عن الاستعدادات
عندك هناك
استعدادات ضخمه للغايه ليث الرئيس العام
لرئاسه الحرمين الشريفين الدكتور عبد
الهاديس اكد وكشف عن جاهزيه المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي لاستقبال الاعداد
المليونيه لهذا العام خاصه بعد جائحه
كورونا واكد انه جرى تجهيز كل المواقع
للمعتمرين والمصلين والزائرين وقصدي
المسجد الحرام وان كافه الخدمات المقدمه
لقصدي المسجد الحرام والمعتمرين ستكون على
احبه الاستعداد باستخدام احدث التقنيات هل
هناك طرق جديده او استعدادات اضيفت لهذا
العام عن الاعوام السابقه
نعم الحاله التشغيليه ليث لجميع السلالم
والمصاعد الكهربائيه منظومه الصوت بجميع
اجزائها الخدمات الفنيه الخدمات الهندسيه
التوعويه الارشاديه كلها جاهزه طبعا مع
الاشراف عليها من قبل فريق مختص للتاكد من
التنفيذ وفق اصول فنيه متبعه باستخدام
احدث التقنيات ليث عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا
لك وان شاء الله بس عندي بعد سؤال خط عربي
سعودي جديد ما قصه هذا الخط
نعم سمر وزاره الثقافه اعلنت يوم امس عن
مبادره الحروف الطباعيه وتم الاعلان عن
ثلاثه خطوط جديده الخط الاول هو خط او حرف
المصمك جاءك اول هذه الخطوط لينسب الى قصر
المصمك الخاص بالملك عبد العزيز الخط
الثاني هو حرف
النسيب المحتضر للطابع البسيط الخط الثالث
سمر هو حرف وتد الماخوذ من وتد الخيمه
وبخط انا سمر وليث هذه رسالتي الى امي
العظيمه والجميله والرائعه امي انت الحياه
الحب مصدر السعاده دائما وابدا الله يخلي
لكم الصحه والعافيه شكرا لك يعني مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي الراقب بدي
اضيف عليه